For me,
you know,
when I was an artist,
a lot of what I did was collage.
I would bring together disparate
elements and then when they be,
when they got side by side,
there is a kind of magical child born
from those disparate elements.
And that's my creative process.
So I'll bring in some music,
maybe unexpected music,
and I'll bring in some readings.
I might take five books and just
randomly open to different pages.
Um,
I might go for a walk.
Uh,
and when these things are placed side by
side,
uh,
interestingly enough,
in the best of circumstances there's a
magical child and that's my creative
process is collage.
It's like being immersed in life rather
than separating yourself.
A person that I look to for inspiration.
Definitely Sharon Gannon.
Oh,
Sharon is the prime mover of Jeeva,
do yoga.
It was her,
her,
uh,
her magical child.
She,
um,
motivates me on a daily basis,
uh,
with her,
her high hopes and her,
um,
her optimism.
I tend to be a little bit pessimistic
and I get mired in that a little bit.
Uh,
what's the use?
And Sharon always brings me back,
uh,
to,
well,
what are you going to do right now in
the next few minutes?
What could you do to make the world a
better place?
And,
and she's constantly filled with new
ideas and new possibilities and new
projects.
So many projects I have to run to keep
[inaudible].